Anyone who has seen the Star Wars films and
dug into the franchise's vast canon knows
that lightsabers come in a variety of colors.
For the most part, Jedi wield sabers that
are blue or green colors that represent the
two biggest schools of thought within the
Jedi Order.
Green is most commonly chosen by the Consulars,
who focus on their mental knowledge of the
Force.
Blue is most often seen in the hands of Jedi
Guardians, who focus on learning combat and
becoming warriors.
Those who have aligned themselves with the
dark side, mostly Sith Lords, flash red lightsabers
in combat.
And as for purple lightsabers?
Mace Windu's violet-colored blade was only
introduced to the franchise because actor
Samuel L. Jackson put in a personal request
to Star Wars creator George Lucas for a lightsaber
bearing his favorite color… and Samuel L.
Jackson gets what Samuel L. Jackson wants.
In the expanded Star Wars universe, however,
there are plenty more colors of lightsabers
to go around.
Although extremely rare, yellow lightsabers
are among them.
Just like the blue and green lightsabers,
the yellow lightsaber is associated with an
important school of thought within the Jedi
Order: that of the Sentinels.
Star Wars lore explains that the Sentinels
seek a balance between the Consulars and the
Guardians, and also wish to educate themselves
on other more practical aspects of life such
as tracking techniques and espionage.
Unlike some others in the Jedi Order, Sentinels
recognize that the Force isn't actually the
solution to everything.
"Mmm, A Jedi uses the Force for knowledge
and defense — never for attack."
The yellow lightsaber is most commonly seen
in the Jedi Temple Guards' pikes on the Star
Wars animated series The Clone Wars.
The Temple Guards wield double-bladed yellow
sabers, much like the dual-ended red weapon
Darth Maul hefted around before it was sliced
in half.
These lightsabers don't personally belong
to the Temple Guards, but are instead the
property of the position they hold.
Additionally, there are other rare sightings
of yellow lightsabers including in the hands
of bounty hunter Asajj Ventress, who apparently
found her lightsaber on the black market.
Ventress' blade was identical to those of
the Jedi, rather than the more blade-like
appearance of the pikes wielded by the Temple
Guard.
Another Star Wars character said to have carried
a yellow lightsaber is Anakin Skywalker's
Padawan learner Ahsoka Tano.
Though George Lucas nixed the idea of Ahsoka
using a full-on yellow saber on Star Wars:
The Clone Wars, Ahsoka's mostly green saber
was altered to give off a slightly yellow
glow.
In essence, a lightsaber's color reveals something
about its wielder and their personality.
Lucasfilm's Pablo Hidalgo has explained that
the Kyber crystals used to make lightsabers
start out colorless.
The crystals only take on a color once they
has been gathered by a Jedi Padawan, and a
bond between the crystal and the Jedi has
been formed during the creation of the lightsaber.
There's even been an instance in which a yellow
saber was made from unstable red saber crystal,
when Jedi Jaden Korr purified it and the crystal
turned yellow, granting him his third lightsaber.
It's been suggested that perhaps the reason
so few yellow sabers are seen in the era of
the Clone Wars is because so few Sentinels
still exist in the Jedi Order, with most Jedi
either falling into the category of Consular
or Guardian.
Another theory is that because the Sentinels
focus so much of their energy on learning
skills outside of the Force, they may still
exist but they remain so low on the radar
that they rarely have to whip out their yellow
lightsabers.
Because of their real-world skills, their
missions outside of the Jedi Temple didn't
require them to use combat.
Instead, they'd resort to their real-world
knowledge that wouldn't have required them
to show off their lightsaber skills.
The Star Wars universe is ever-expanding,
with new movies and TV shows coming even after
the Skywalker saga concludes.
Lucasfilm is currently preparing to launch
an Obi-Wan Kenobi series on the Disney+ streaming
platform to follow the first live-action Star
Wars show, The Mandalorian.
With any luck, fans may see yellow lightsabers
in all their glory all over the place in the
years to come.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.